like infinity war before it Avengers
endgame is a marvel of storytelling but
is the execution perfect
not really throughout its three hour run
time and game take some narrative turns
that Teeter on the edge of nonsense and
some of the screenwriters choices
threaten to ruin the movie if you think
about them too hard
here are the biggest plot holes and
Avengers endgame that everybody just
ignored during the film's time heist
Bruce Banner visits the sanctum
sanctorum in 2012 New York City he's
searching for Doctor Strange to borrow
the time Stoney's known to guard but
instead of strange he finds the ancient
one strange his mentor who doesn't meet
the doctor until the events of his movie
in 2016
despite strange not yet being the
sorcerer supreme the ancient one has
full knowledge of who he is and hearing
that he gives away the time stone in the
future is enough to convince her to give
up her own stone that's how much he
trusts strange saying strange is meant
to be the best of us it's presented as a
foregone conclusion a predestined future
that she's already aware of but this
doesn't match up with what we've seen
before
in the Doctor Strange movie the ancient
one presents private doubts as to
whether she'll even train strange
confiding in Mordor that she cannot take
him on as a student
Ward o has to convince her to train in
which flatly contradicts endgame it
makes sense for the ancient one to put
up a front first range himself but why
would she doubt him when he's not even
in the room it's not magic just a little
plot hole between movies I never saw
your future only its possibilities just
as Peter quill since the Avengers plan
off the rails an infinity war nebula
nearly ruins everything an end game
thanks to her always on Wi-Fi the cyborg
daughter of Thanos is found captured and
replaced by her younger counterpart in
2014 with her past self following the
Avengers into the future on thanasis
behalf once there she flipped some
switches on the team's quantum tunnel
targets Thanos a ship and opens a portal
to bring him through afterwards the
final battle kicks in so fast you're
left with no time to figure out what
exactly just happened when the Avengers
nebula is sent back to help retrieve the
Power Stone she leaves with only enough
Pym particles for a return trip
particles which 2014 nebula presumably
uses in her place she then uses the
quantum tunnel to target families a ship
and pull it into the future with
thanasis ships somehow able to enter the
quantum realm without the help of any
Pym particles or technology also if it's
possible for the 2014 nebula to target
objects and pull them through time why
did
the Avengers do exactly that with the
Infinity stones themselves if nebula can
bring a ship through why couldn't they
bring some rocks through you can come up
with all kinds of solutions for this and
reportedly the Russo brothers have begun
explaining and interviews that the Pym
particles were reverse engineered by
Thanos and Abba nema but even if that's
the case the movie doesn't show any of
this it just starts the explosions and
crosses its fingers hoping you won't
think too hard about it at the end of
infinity war seeing those kills half of
the universe at the snap of his fingers
it's a flourish that's ripped straight
out of the comic books and a gesture
that became instantly iconic but endgame
treats snapping your fingers as though
it's an essential part of the way the
gauntlet works so much so that Captain
Marvel is able to stop their nose from
destroying the universe during the
movies final battle I holding on to his
finger is preventing him from pulling
off a snap but here's the thing
you shouldn't have to snap your fingers
to exert the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet this isn't how it works in the
comics or the movies while the fairness
of the movies does usually close his
fist while wielding the gauntlets powers
it doesn't appear that he really has to
and the fact that the snap does anything
kind of proves that it just seems like
something he does more for the audience
once Thanos gets the gauntlet on his
hand he should be able to rewrite
reality with little more than sheer
willpower from what the movies and the
comics that inspired them have shown us
you don't need to snap your fingers to
have it grant your wish
relative to all the movies that came
before it and game is like a fire hose a
fanservice especially the final battle
in which dozens of characters line up to
fight like a living comic splash page
it's an event that fans have spent years
waiting for but plenty of people still
had to ask what exactly is Pepper Potts
doing there we can readily accept the
notion that the CEO of Stark Industries
has become proficient at piloting your
own rescue armor over the years it's not
a stretch of the imagination that she
learned the ropes of combat off screen
especially after Iron Man 3 saw her
vanquish the villain herself while
briefly supercharged by extremis she has
as much of a right to fight as anybody
else in the MCU but the question is who
called her the epic return of all the
Avengers post survival is implied to
have been coordinated by Doctor Strange
who got ahold of the other sorcerers on
earth and immediately said about
reuniting every fighter for a showdown
at Avengers HQ but how did he know to
call Pepper who didn't suit up in her
own Iron Man armor until long after
Strange was dead they only met for like
a second will he even know where she
lives
that phone call go hey pepper its Steve
heading upstate for the final battle
come through bring a gun or something
whatever the specifics are of who got a
hold of her so fast we now live in a
universe where pepper freakin Potts got
a shot off on Thanos and that's pretty
remarkable whether you like it or not
much is made of the stakes at play in
the Avengers time high scamp it on top
of playing with forces they don't quite
understand facing a threat that soundly
beat them before the Avengers are also
dealing with limited resources as Scott
Lang tells everyone the time-travel
trickery of the quantum realm relies
entirely on the proprietary Pym
particles invented by Hank Pym who in
death isn't able to create any more of
them if they use up their supply on the
heist without succeeding they lose but
the answer to this conundrum is right in
front of the Avengers the whole time and
it's kind of shocking that Scott a
career thief doesn't think of it instead
of starting off their journey by trying
to get the stones why didn't they begin
by going back in time and stealing all
of the Pym particles they were going to
need if the pass can be mine for
Infinity stones and magic hammers it can
certainly be mine for Pym particles even
if they use them up and don't return
them and can just invent more sure it's
possible that's stealing the particles
and not replacing them will create a
slightly different time line but this
hardly feels like a big transgression
considering all the other Maverick
improvisation the team gets up to during
the heist the only reason the writers
didn't take this route is probably
because it would have lowered the stakes
everyone's got an opinion about Captain
America going back into the past to live
a life with Peggy Carter some people
love it while others think it betrays
his character we're not concerned about
any of that we're just trying to figure
out how old cap showed up in the prime
timeline and game makes its time-travel
rules very clear it's not Back to the
Future style we're changing the past can
change the future here's how professor
Hulk explains it if you travel to the
past that past becomes your future and
your former present becomes the past
which can't now be changed by your new
future it's all pretty simple changes to
the past caused different timelines so
why and how does Captain America going
to the Past in the prime timeline into
him growing old and living a life in the
prime timeline changed in the MCU so far
Steve Rogers has gone under the ice
hibernated for nearly 70 years and been
revived to live a decade or so as one of
the Earth's Mightiest Heroes as endgame
closes he goes back into the past to
catch up on that date he miss a Peggy
that past is now his future a new future
into
the one he previously hibernated in it
should have caused an alternate timeline
instead it's implied that Steve went to
the past of the prime timeline which
completely goes against how Hulk says
time travel works some people believe
that Steve going into the past and
living out his days as Peggy's husband
is a simple closed loop that he always
married Peggy and just stayed off screen
during young Steve's reunion with old
Peggy during their meet up in the Winter
Soldier in this theory there have always
been two Steve's ones just been secretly
retired he saved over a thousand men
including the man who would dead who
would become my husband as it turned out
that's a weird way to put it but okay
here's another question then where did
old Steve get a shield and game's final
battle results in the destruction of
Captain America shield leaving it
cleaved in two by Thanos has played he
does not take the shield back to the
Past with him but when old Steve shows
up next to the pond he is a shield in
pristine condition how if Steve's time
hopping life is a closed loop then there
should only be one shield to go around
if cap somehow stole his own shield
while his younger self was onto the ice
and that would mean there would be no
shield for his younger self to receive
upon waking up reading exactly the kind
of paradox that this movie's time-travel
roles are supposed to avoid so is old
cap from another timeline and just came
over to drop his shield off with Falcon
if so how do you get back to the prime
timeline as a 100 something year old man
maybe it's not the real cap at all maybe
it's just a gigantic plot hole that'd be
best to stop thinking about check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]